قال مندوب روسيا لدى الامم المتحده
فاسيلين بن زياد ان بلاده توجه ضربات
باسلحه دقيقه للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه التي
تستخدم لاغراض عسكريه وانه كان يتضرب
بنيتها التحتيه وتحاول اتهام روسيا بذلك
ضد البنيه التحتيه للطاقه وغيرها التي
تستخدم لمد القوات الاوكرانيه باسلحه
وبعد ذلك
سيمبا
على تحويل منشات الطاقه الاوكرانيه الى
روكام دوافع بوت واضحه وقاسيه من الواضح
انه يستخدم فصل الشتاء كسلاح لالحاق
المعاناه بالشعب الاوكراني لقد قرر انه
اذا لم يستطع الاستيلاء على اوكرانيا
بالقوه فسيحاول تجميد البلاد واخضاعها
نظرا لصعوبات التي تواجهها موسكو في ساحه
المعركه فانها تتبنى الانستراتيجيه جبانه
وغير انسانيه لمعاقبه الاوكرانيين رجالا
ونسانا واطفال